um i mean also does that mean you should
go crazy risk i don't think so we're off
with the muzo so here we go is it crazy
uh yeah
dude we'll have something to say about
that maybe
i now have seen him play h4 in that
position but he didn't play it we have a
groomfield instead
a mainline grunfeld defense and we
haven't seen too much of the grenfell
defense lately uh i'm among these guys
at least uh in the oslo esports cup but
it is a very counter-attacking opening i
haven't seen duda play this too often
and i feel like dude is hiding opening
preparation for the candidates later
this summer and uh prague has great
memories in this type of opening i've
seen him win actually quite a few games
lately prague on the white side of this
position so the grunfeld defense white
gets the center with pawns black tries
to chip away at the center from afar
black also the first to castle look at
the black bishop in front of the black
king that is a great piece on the long
diagonal simon we've even had yeah
against each other yeah i've had this
exact position on the white side and
david's had it on the black side david's
uh a big gruntfield player and i
i quite like the center and trying to
build up an attack from the center uh i
think i've pushed the h pawn by now
though probably when i've played you
david
this is this is one of the the sort of
modern lines isn't it where where black
just keeps attention and here grabbing
the pawn uh again uh an idea which has
been played quite commonly yeah so dudes
previous move the last move allowing
black allowing white sorry to grab a
pawn like this isn't necessarily the
most popular way of playing but it's
quite trendy as you mentioned there
simon has come into fashion lately and
white is one pawn up now but white's
pawns on the c file they are doubled
white has a lot of weaknesses long term
so there's compensation and duda he's
going after some of white's weak pawns
with the black queen look how duda he's
looking off to his left uh it's alright
on the screen but when a player looks
off to their left it means they're
trying to remember something that means
he's studied this before he's just
trying to recall what the computer said
and uh pragnanda he's just simply in his
own theory he's studied this before he
knows exactly what to do so he's simply
waiting for duder's response
do you also feel a jolt of joy when you
get your opening preparation in i mean
it happens so rarely
i don't get that joy much but um it's so
nice i mean it i think i played a
tournament recently in reykjavik and in
one game out of nine i got my
preparation in and it was such a nice
relief because
you're suddenly like oh the stress is
off i've put this on the computer i know
my position is okay you can relax a
little bit more and your opponent has to
start sweating but uh here prague
clearly in his prep still yeah yeah what
do you mean by getting your opening prep
in
what what happens
well basically you've studied that
position at home and
basically the opponent does
what you have prepared exactly you're
hoping he will do exactly and uh usually
you know you feel a great sense of
relief because you're like hey i know
what to do and you don't
and that of course gives gives a lot of
pleasure um i have to admit sometimes it
doesn't give me so much pleasure to get
my opening preparation in
when i know that the opening line is
like several moves long and i can't
remember like beyond a certain point
then i'm like oh i really hope that they
don't just carry don't just sound how
fine
and it becomes a little bit stressful
all right well in this one we're
wondering if pragnanda has gotten his
opening prep in he is and also with his
coach ramesh and that must be nice at
this point david after losing a game to
go back to his lounge meet ramesh
and maybe forget about that first game
exactly ramesh is one of the best chess
coaches out there in the world he's so
experienced especially with the younger
players coaching them and ramesh he will
have been full of words of wisdom
helping maybe just stay calm focus on
the next game maybe they've discussed
this exact position together as well
if not for duda then for sure in a
previous game and look at that duda
spent two minutes or so thinking about
black's move prank reacted instantly we
talk about prep being prepared
predicting the opponent's moves and
prague's done that this is a pawn
sacrifice
and it must be prep because dude has
taken the pawn immediately yeah and has
been played before and uh there you can
see
black moves forward with the queen but
that doesn't matter because uh pragnanda
has it all under control he's looked at
this before and he slides his rook over
two squares to support the pawn
and uh here there haven't been too many
games i have to say only two and uh
black has played
actually developed black has actually
developed a light squared bishop one
square in that game
okay and uh that's a very typical move
here very standard move you need to
connect your rooks this rook especially
is the worst place piece on the board
the only only piece which hasn't really
moved so by moving your bishop forward
you connect your rooks maybe get ready
to centralize here later on simon you
mentioned the word pawn sacrifice i
guess in the current position yes white
gave away a central pawn but still white
does have these two pawns so it's level
material for now
it's just surprising that white gave up
this really key central pawn right uh i
guess black had to lose a lot of time
with the queen the queen now having
moved one two three four times already
in the game in the first 15 moves and i
think after uh maybe a potential rook
lift by white
um because you've got to look at your
opponent's queen and you're thinking
that queen's really annoying when anyone
moves a piece into your half uh try to
kick it away and as david is
demonstrating there that rook coming up
the board would again kick the queen
away probably to the queen side so the
black queen now is in danger because if
the bishop moves there'd be a nasty
attack again that black queen probably
wants to get out the danger so it has to
go all the way back
away from the the the side of the ball
where i feel there could be a bit of
action because if you look at white's
pieces white's light square bishop i
know there's pawns in the way but it's
pointing directly at black's king and at
some point there might be a move like
pawn to pawn to f5 this move here to
open up lines and with black's pieces on
the other side of board you should be
looking at these kind of ideas just to
open up the position just to attack i
don't know if it works here but this is
the kind of idea which is uh key to look
at force your opponent's pieces away
from the king attack the king and uh
this this would seem pretty natural yeah
um looks very scary there for black that
type of thing happening and maybe that's
why dude is hesitating also it's a
psychological blow when you you're i
mean you're at move 16 now and you know
your opponent has played instantly every
single move prague has gained two
minutes from when he started the game uh
so dude maybe inside he's trying to keep
calm but he's trying not to panic at the
same time uh so yeah it's looking like
this type of idea for white maybe in the
air maybe this one simon as well your
favorite later just i like backing
against the black king definitely it's
uh shaping up to be an exciting game
we like to hear that um i just noticed
the bar in game two with liam lee and
anish geary has already shot up for liam
lee
and apparently anish giri is
shaking his head
has he made a blunder in that game look
at the anish giri this is after only
seven eight minutes of that game
i'm not sure about a blunder but
something odd has happened for anish i
have a feeling later he's gonna say it
was a mouse slip uh but he castled the
okay he's laughing that and he's scary
he castled the black king towards the
queen side where it's probably going to
just get checkmated so he's just walked
into
what's going to happen i mean something
bad that's going to happen soon
um i just have a feeling he meant to
move the black rook instead of his king
he's got to get used to the mouse hasn't
he
yeah he's really struggling with his
mouse movements you know i mean lawrence
was um laurence trent who we got in the
studio uh was mentioning he plays a lot
online and he got repetitive wrist
syndrome um i guess from practicing
online um but i think it's something to
be careful of i don't know the technical
term of it but again moving that mouse
anish is uh struggling
a lot you need that you need to get uh
into the connection of playing online
chats and you know even basic things
such as like sam and says moving the
mouse getting accustomed to when you
pre-move and uh again also coping with
the fact that the the board isn't 2d as
opposed to its usual 3d when you're
playing over the board so i mean but uh
i mean anish does have great support he
has a fantastic second here with him
irwin lamy and as we've seen time and
time again it's very very important to
have the right network behind you and uh
well for anish but what's happening here
yep just the move we expected for black
from duda and uh pregnant reacting
instantly again he's played 17 moves in
a row instantly
just improved the white queen actually
getting ready for something similar to
what simon showed just he's getting
ready to bring one of the rooks across
to challenge and kick away the black
queen out of his half of the board all
right pragnanda he's under pressure he
lost game one and chasing him from
behind is magnus carlsen he is playing a
match against eric hanson
magnus he won game one and let's hear
what magnus and eric said after that
first game
well this good start today you win the
first game and uh do you still eye the
tournament championship now
uh yeah i mean
i i said many years ago that uh
as long as it's theoretically possible
then i always try to win the tournament
so
as far as i can tell it's still
theoretically possible
and how do you feel physically today
a bit better than
than the two days before
perhaps most importantly how do you view
real madrid's chances in the second game
against manchester city
about the same as
before the first game
good luck in both this tournament and
that rematch yeah thank you
uh eric you start out in a tough way
against carlson how are you going to get
back into this match i have no idea i'm
blundering
everything i
don't even know
what's wrong with me right now like last
few days in about one or two games each
day
i'm making some of the worst moves like
possible like
this is just embarrassing um i don't
know i don't have any words to be honest
uh
i can't explain a couple of the moves
i've been making and they're game losing
they're they're
i i'm making moves that i know are bad i
i don't know what's up with me right now
um
but uh that was one of the worst games
i've ever played
it's perhaps hard for us who do not play
chess on
that level but but when when you go
through those kind of moves in your head
in advance
is it an instinctual move that you feel
go wrong or is it the calculation wise
where you feel you get lost in it
it's a calculation thing but something's
off with my
intuition as well
but
you know just a couple times
i meant to play something and i played
something different
i don't know how to explain it but i uh
these are like game losing mistakes that
that you just can't afford to lose
concentration or
get your lines mixed up in your head so
i i really don't know how to explain it
but
i'm not really
playing what i mean to play in some
situations and it's costing me
can it sometimes be easier to get out of
that funk by ending
by starting up one game down and maybe
freeing up a little bit in your game
style
no no i mean you still need wind you
still need confidence and uh
i mean i've lost like two or three days
in a row so i
at this point
even a draw is usually a positive sign
that means i didn't blunder too much but
can't even get something like that i
mean these are these are some horrible
games that i'm playing
thank you for taking the time to work
thanks
eric hansen he is actually super
frustrated even if he is facing the
world champion today he did win his
match against mamadiaro a few days ago
but
other than that he has lost all his
matches
hard to hear eric be this frustrated
yeah it's hard to hear and these days
we're used to players being quite open
and honest but again that's one side
that they don't talk about so much is
the mental health and the toll it takes
on you playing such intense chess high
pressure chess day in day out and eric
he talked about that mental health
aspect on our podcast
uh but yeah i mean it's it's hard to see
him struggle so much here i mean he had
one win early in the tournament he was
so happy but that's the problem with
chess
every single defeat takes so much out of
you
can really knock the confidence and yeah
you gotta feel for him and that podcast
the late night show with eric hansen as
a special guest will be released
tomorrow a special video edition to all
chess 24 premium users other than that
the podcast is available wherever you
listen to your podcast but but mental
health then will be a big theme in that
podcast yeah and eric the reason or one
of the reasons he's so well known as a
streamer is because he decided to turn
his back on professional chess and just
playing tournaments living out of a
suitcase because the pressure is so much
and it's so hard to make a living so
hard to keep going motivating yourself
picking yourself up from defeats and um
yeah i mean it's been tough for eric
he's just come up against some of the
best players in the world and he hasn't
played that badly i mean of course he's
going to be harsh with himself
you always are when you lose but he
hasn't played that badly it's just in
situations like this it's it's it's hard
yeah i mean uh yeah
the same i i mean it's it's actually
quite sad uh because he's been so happy
throughout the tournament so far every
interview he's been upbeat even when
he's lost and that interview is like wow
it's turn around it's actually probably
his real emotions in some respects it's
very easy to hide them
but it is really painful losing and it
is so important to
to you know uh to to refocus for him and
just remember like so many other good
things going on uh but yeah we should
all send him a lot of love and i hope he
gets hopefully it will take magnus down
now take him down eric yeah for the boys
does he say for the boys it was it was
quite hard actually hearing that
interview and just hearing the raw
emotion but one thing he doesn't have to
worry about is that he still has the
love admiration and respect from
everyone who's cheering for him because
you know we are asking who are you
rooting for and why and i can tell you a
lot of answers a lot of viewers are
cheering for eric and you know they're
saying canada is proud of you eric we
love seeing you shake up these world
players and okay yeah i mean it's
difficult it's hard to
suffer these defeats time and time again
but uh i i do hope that he does go on to
twitter at some point reads these
messages of support and uh
feel some motivation or just think about
them and then when he sits down at the
computer and he gets ready to play the
next game that he can just smile yeah
and uh just enjoy the game yeah send him
some love you guys eric hansen he needs
it what a great player and what a great
person what a great streamer he is he
needs the love and i bet everyone
cheering for pragnanda in the tournament
is also hoping eric will do good against
magnus today
prague is down by one point against duda
and with the white pieces here do you
see chances for prague to win this game
david definite chances for prague it's a
really imbalanced position we talked
about the pawn structure earlier it's a
bit of a weird pawn structure prague
long term not doing well because white
has doubled pawns shattered pawns on the
left half
but he's so active prague really nice
centralized pieces i like where white's
bishops are right now it's all about
whether he can attack and for the first
real time in the game prague is thinking
he's got a six minute time advantage and
i think the next two or three moves are
critical he's played great up to this
point of course with the help of his
opening preparation but it's about
whether he can back it up if he can get
an attack i think prague is a big
favorite but if he can't whip up some
kind of energy some kind of activity now
on the next few moves then
it's all going to turn into just favor
yeah i mean we could look at a couple of
moves on the analysis board and uh the
first very obvious move which i think
we're probably all thinking of i'd
imagine is
just looking at the aspects of the
position we talked about the black queen
going to the other side of board
look at the king the black king is
defended by one piece it's only defended
by the bishop in front of it so when
you're trying to start an attack you've
got to try and look at the defenders and
remove those defenders so a logical move
here would be to just push the bishop
into the center and try to get rid of
the dark square bishops remove the last
defender of black's king and then you
can think about getting your other
pieces into the attack maybe with that
sacrifice we talked about earlier or
maybe even by using the h pawn as david
pointing out but this seems like a very
sensible way to start get rid of that
defender and then just throw everything
at the black king because it has no
pieces
around it supporting it so
that would be certainly what i i'd be
thinking here and i'd be very uh well
i'm always totally overconfident when
i'm attacking it's a big mistake
probably but i'd be really happy here
and i i think when you get that
happiness in your position you play
better in some respects as well you get
you know that confidence helps a lot but
yeah that looks like a sensor move
doesn't it i think it's i mean it's the
first move that came to my mind as well
and you're right there if you like the
position if you understand it then you
always
play better you can play quicker as well
because of the confidence you get and
it's not just the fact that this is a
good attacking move trying to remove
black's best defender but also it's a
good strategic move so if black ever
takes your bishop then suddenly you can
correct the fact that you have doubled
pawns which is never comfortable you can
correct that by playing pawn takes
bishop suddenly connecting your pawns up
again and as simon mentioned once that
black bishop disappears so many
weaknesses around the black king you
could easily imagine the white knight
suddenly jumping into some holes uh so
yeah that's the move i would choose as
well prague he's spent four minutes now
he's this is a
problem his time management has been a a
little bit a little bit dodgy so yeah
but it just seems such a natural move i
i don't even know why you you're
thinking about playing anything else
here get rid and he's played it but yes
taking that long to play that move just
seems a bit odd when that's a third of
nearly a third of your time i notice
it's a trend though normally even the
best prepared players in the world those
who know their openings uh better than
anyone else normally as soon as they
meet their first move they don't know or
that they don't recognize they always
spend a long long time just to kind of
get into the game because prague
basically he hasn't played any moves
himself up to that point so maybe it's
the first move he's on his own where he
hasn't kind of had the computer or his
coach's help
studying beforehand
so yeah maybe just on fresh terms he was
just kind of trying to get into the game
into the position i mean there's some
really i mean f5 next to me looks like
it could well be a threat this is uh
pushing the pawn in front of the queen
because now you've just got to open
those lines you've got to calculate
these things very carefully but there's
one really interesting line i can see
okay he's taken that one as david
pointed out but
this this also seems a bit strange
because
as david said white's pawns become
better now they undouble
and they become friends
friends
they can hold hands
jump in each other's cars wasn't it that
scene from in between us yeah not my
friend
yeah i'm also a little bit puzzled by
that decision as well because
white can even start thinking about
taking radical measures right push the
pawn push the push
explode it open create a revolution um
and presumably i mean judo is counting
on the fact that that queen tucked away
on a6
if the revolution happens and white just
launches the pawn forward the queen can
maybe get to
the uh some squares safely
maybe she can defend her king later on
but as simon says it looks super scary
um okay i'm surprised prague didn't push
this pawn forward instead
instead he moved his rook which was
attacked so taking the safe option and
now duda he was so scared of this idea
exploding open lines towards the black
king that he decided to stop it he
pushed the pawn himself this is very
very weakening for black but i think it
was essential to stop white's pawn
pushing forward also taking away this
key square for the white knight uh the
black pawn now preventing that so why is
it weakening it's weakening because look
at the black king now it's always
weakening to push pawns in front of it
and here black has pushed two pawns in
front of his king like your body goes
around
you know your pawns are like your
personal bodyguards that protect you and
when you when your bodyguards are
running away it leaves you open but uh
but i i i don't know i mean prank's
decision i mean he
i would have liked to have seen that
airborne push and just some crazy attack
going yeah it's still looking good for
prague we should mention he's got
complete control of the dart squares
especially in the center these pawns are
actually really strong just stopping
black from pushing any pawns but
suddenly prague has a dilemma how does
he activate his knight his knight has
lost access to these keys central
squares and also his bishop if he tries
to improve it if he tries to bring it
opposite the black king then it just
gets traded off for the black knight
so he still needs to solve that issue
how to improve this piece this piece
maybe improve the queen as well at some
point uh it's looking very good for
prague long term but short term some
questions to answer i'm gonna try to see
if i've learned anything now david so uh
for duda now yes his king is on one side
and all his pieces on the other side is
that
a big problem for him yes okay big
problem for black
and that's why prague if he can i mean
that's why simon wanted to break through
and sacrifice open up the black king
while the black pieces were offside i
still kind of still do david i mean i'm
thinking a very natural idea but push
the pawn in the center here i i mean i
don't know if i can back it up with
anything but something like this
is trying to open up more lines for
example if i capture you yeah i mean
that's the thing
i wanted to try something on f5 but we
don't quite have enough i feel for this
this is a type of idea right and this
shows kaya's point as well yes you might
have sacrificed a piece here for white
but suddenly the black king is
completely open completely naked lost
all of its bodyguards and suddenly the
black knight the white knight sorry on
f5 where it always thrives and the white
queen about to sneak in with some sneaky
threats
all of these pieces are on the wrong
side of the board right now so this type
of thing is going through prague's mind
for sure i have a sneaky feeling he's
looking at this move
you can see prague kind of leaning
forward okay he chooses another
attacking move always a good move david
always a good move gary on the run get
ready to soften up the right side of the
board
um
and duda quickly moving his rook in the
center i mean he's getting ready just to
initiate his counter play there you know
i guess he has to i mean after all he
just has to wait for whatever prague has
in store for him on the right
and uh the rules do say they're very
clear
although there's always exceptions to
the rule that uh if your opponent works
on the side of the board you should work
on the way on the center
so you guys are liking it for prague
right now i'm liking it for prague but
the next few moves still critical it's
just about whether he can improve the
white knight the white bishop whether he
can break through to the black king
because those three black pieces on the
wrong side of the board that we
highlighted if they gravitate towards
the center suddenly black might be doing
quite well so it's just about timing if
he can't find anything within the next
three moves then the black pieces have
time to centralize and duda will be
completely fine but if you find
something now on the next two moves
prague
there would be time for black species to
rejoin the battle
for me the critical piece is the white
knight it has no purpose whatsoever at
the minute and yeah i
like just visualizing it i'm just like
well i would love that it could move
diagonally
in front of his pawns and just plonk it
in the e5 square where it's supported by
two of its pawns love that or maybe just
anywhere on the dark squares basically
so if you talk to the the white knight
right now because you guys have taught
me talk to your pieces and ask it where
do you want to be where does that white
knight want to be on the e5 square yeah
ivanka mentioned uh the white knight we
talk about knights in general and this
is something ivanka taught me a phrase
i'd never ever heard before until i
joined the tour uh an octonite and a
knight in the center of the board is
called an octonaut because it controls
eight squares it's like an octopus with
eight legs the knight here does not
control eight squares um it doesn't
control i mean there's uh no line after
the h line so it doesn't control one
side of the board that's why we say
don't put your knights on the side here
the white knight's okay and the black
knight is properly on the side of the
board but either way both of them want
to be centralized both of them could be
improved so uh
first both sides taking a time out to
improve their rooks instead but but how
can prague get that white knight to that
dream square this is the problem yeah
it's actually a really good training
question as well and you you know often
i i say when i used to coaching is if
you could just remove the knight from
the board or you just trace the sort of
route so you can see which square you
want to put it on and you just try to
find the quickest route for the night to
get there
and this is how people work out
maneuvers basically it's how you
maneuver in chess you know by by just
taking it off the board and working back
but it's really hard to get it to that
square and you've got to think about
timing and you don't really have enough
time your three genius minds together
yeah how can we get to the square the
problem is you want to use this square
and then as simon said you want to trace
your way you want to go one two three oh
whoops not there
there sorry one two three into the
center and a niche mouse slip yeah slip
so
here you're three squares away from
getting to the center but the problem is
after one move you get stopped
immediately you'll get traded off by
this black bishop and uh suddenly no
more knight no more dream square for it
in the middle of the board
so if you can't use this square how do
you ever get to the middle you need for
example maybe to go backwards the only
square you can't be captured but you
don't want to put a knight in the corner
then you need another move for example
if black just waits you need another
move to get your queen out of the way
you need another move to bring your
knight forward but still how do you get
to the square any time you march forward
and try to get there you just get traded
off by the black bishop this is very
famous nimsovich maneuver actually he he
did something similar he came to h3g5
and around that in one one of his games
but it's lovely when you can move the
knight back to get in the position but
again you've got to work out if you have
the time to do that and
black has this pressure in the center
now so i just don't think you have the
time to but does he have any moves to
get that black light squared
bishop out of the way which seems to be
the problem to get the knight there this
is also another solution that you can
approach you say problem that light
squared bishop therefore get rid of it i
like the way you're thinking yeah so how
about pushing the a pawn for example i
like the way you feel great
this is really good stuff
yeah imagine if he plays it now which he
might because it's very logical yeah
yeah
kyle you're getting a high five from me
this is brilliant yeah
yeah the one downside if the black
bishop goes back this way you're very
happy because now the white knight can
start to reroute itself
and it can't get captured but the
problem is the black bishop might just
keep itself on this diagonal and the
white knight still can't use that square
so still a bit tricky that's why prague
hasn't pushed his pawn yet um this pawn
push that uh i i think we all want to
see now after kayaking suggested it
definitely yeah
this is the move where we're cheering
i'm exhausted now thinking about all
these it's hot it's tiring to be a chess
player yeah that's exactly what's going
through prague's mind as well i have a
feeling he's going to either push alice
the a-pawn or push harry
the h-born yeah he's going to play on
one of the flanks yeah but you're right
i mean mentioning the tiredness thing
this is something that all chess players
are you know it's really hard because uh
you can imagine at home if you haven't
played until doing doing the hardest
exam of your life
but you're doing it uh potentially these
guys for four or five hours each day
and they can't make mistakes they've got
to stay concentrating you're doing that
every day and the mental fatigue uh that
that you can get from it is is extreme
we've all done that in tournaments where
we've played for like 10 days on the row
and david has the longest games as well
he'd be the last person to finish at the
same time oh okay
this is
this is either very good
it's about saying either very good or
very very bad so white push that pawn to
try and break the connection with
black's queen on the sixth rank uh so
actually again we got to show this
because prague he's trying to go for
what we call a genius move but it might
backfire uh so he's pushed his pawn
forward it can actually be captured in
four different ways this pawn but if it
gets captured by the black queen in
order for the black queen to keep in
contact with this pawn then suddenly
disaster for black note how the white
rook stands opposite the queen so the
white bishop will jump out of the way
take a pawn attacking the queen and
about to win more pawns on the next go
black is doomed here so black cannot
capture this pawn with the queen that's
one trap that prank has set for duda but
if duda for example takes in a more
natural way maybe
centralizing the night we've been
talking about knights a lot then after
white takes his pawn with the white rook
maybe there's just going to be simple
moves maybe black can take this pawn
maybe black can take this pawn with the
black queen
and okay we're going to see this and the
black queen attacks this rook
i'm not sure prague is quite in time to
break through to the black king there's
no time for the white bishop to enter
this diagonal anymore towards the black
king because the black queen controls so
many squares and
i think this move actually may be key
for duda if you take in the centre of
the board with the black rook
i think simon's ideas are coming to play
there will be a sacrifice on this square
i'm not sure which way white should take
but suddenly the black king comes under
massive pressure so that's the move
we're looking for taking the pawn but
the queen seems like such a strong idea
you're combining attack with defense
you're attacking you're winning a pawn
but you'll bring your queen back uh to
defend as well and you're stopping
white's light square bishop get into
this key square that that
unless white's got a big blow here and
white really needs to have a big blow if
duda does take the pawn uh and i can't
see it because uh it's just not i mean
you're not quite there black's got that
rook defending and i can't seem too slow
i think i mean you would love to for
example plant your queen in the center
defend your rook and also line up to put
your bishop on this diagonal but the
promise you'll one move too slow and in
some variations i think black can maybe
just take your pawn
attacking the bishop attacking the rook
and yes white can give some checks maybe
this is what prague is relying on but
the black king can just move maybe and
i'm not sure there's a follow-up
very complicated still though i'm not
gonna write it off right now yet at
least for prague i think he's got
chances okay wow dramatic he did lose
the first game prague
that would be uh
very dramatic if he loses game two as
well okay and he has taken the pawn with
his queen you know he has shown that uh
he has ice water in his veins i mean
it's so well calculated though because
when you're objective about it you're
like yeah yeah okay it's just a rook yes
i can hide my king but uh emotionally
it feels scary
it really does you know you're the
checks definitely because you know the
checks that you highlighted they
looked it looked wild and it's never
ever comfortable playing
when your opponent is attacking your
king and your king is also open
this can be very interesting as well i
mean if we think about the max match
situation in the tournament situation if
if prague
he may well lose this match uh dude has
won the first uh
first game and um uh magnus may well win
that match so how is that going to fit
things does that mean magnus overtakes
prague then yeah uh going into the last
round but of course they'll all be down
to their individual encounters and uh
i'm just trying to work out who magnus
is playing in the last round with roman
europe which he has got a very good
score against but majority is so
unpredictable i know if you get him on
his day he can crush everyone so
you know it's it could come that what it
will come down to the last day which is
great we want that and in the tour
finals right magnus played mamadyarov
and mamjara won all his white games and
took it to blitz library
i went all the way to armageddon right
and now speaking of mom and er of ah he
loses
game two here to jordan farm for east
and uh the first game i'm forgetting how
that ended i think we all i think it was
true
the first one was a draw all right so
that means juden is in the lead in this
match
and momodaro he has to make a comeback
in game three or four to take it to tie
breaks tomorrow he will face magnus
carlsen
in a match that could be deciding for
the whole tournament
yeah i mean this position though is so
crazy the more i look at it the more i
think it's actually very difficult for
dude and maybe we can get stockfish as
the suggestions from the computer i
don't know if that's possible um there
we go okay blackmoon only has two moves
to keep the advantage one of them i
showed the black knight jumping into the
center that has been played by duda
unfortunately for prague that was maybe
the most obvious move in the position it
does look good for black but there are
some checks white's rook is going to
come up the board with a check
and actually after being given more time
the evaluation bar not so clear um so
the computer even changing its mind
white giving a check i don't think you
can touch this rook as black if you take
this rook off the board you might be in
big trouble you have to move your king
towards the center brook takes rook
would have been met by the white queen
zooming up as it's still very
complicated yeah sorry dave i mean i i
guess uh the key move here is if white
can bring his other rook on that on that
open e file uh this is if this move
works then uh i mean i mean even the
computer whatever the computer is saying
oh yeah what's happening here with the
computer well i mean i think i think if
prague's done this
maybe he's thought maybe he's outdone
the computer is that possible i think
it's a computer the longer it looks at
it the longer it uh it kind of studies
the position the more it favors white
and maybe we can get the computer moves
up again just before we jump into the
position uh because what does the
computer want to do and simon you're
right white only has one move to stay in
the game everything else is pretty much
hopeless for prague
but it is the move you suggested simon
and prague should find this it's
findable even with one and a half
minutes on the clock uh prague he looked
down at the white rook a second ago
let's jump in let's show what he has to
find prague is he going to play it uh
he's got to bring his white rook this
rook that's not in the game he's got to
bring it into the attack rook to the e1
square as the computer shows us look at
this teamwork three heavy pieces three
major pieces on the open file the
problem is you've got to see that you
can give away this bishop you can
actually give this bishop away for free
because here you can check the black
king and there's nowhere to hide for the
black king the black rook if it trades
then suddenly this is a check and a
double attack black's king is actually
going to run into some checkmates here
uh the black king just too exposed so
this is the key move he has to find
prague it's not 100 easy but he should
really find it
and uh he has under a minute though
he'll find it he will find it he's uh so
calm he practiced on calculation and
tactics i think so i mean he'll find it
i can see his screen is it possible to
see what kind of pieces he's
highlighting let's maybe go back to his
screen here he hasn't clicked on a piece
his mouse is at his kind of cursor is at
the top of the screen
surprising it's really surprising it's
so natural bring the other rook in i
mean i think there was at least some
perpetual draw ideas i mean draw ideas
for that but now
i this is too passive you've got no
attack here your two pawns down he wants
to open up the white rook now we
mentioned bringing it across the board
two a couple of moves ago was the key
move he wants to open up the white rook
now to jump to the seventh rank so there
is some idea behind his uh behind his
last couple of moves but as simon
mentioned it's passive and the black
queen now has the luxury of a move to
just jump back to the defense i'm
expecting the black queen to go the
whole way back on the diagonal actually
as close to her king as possible and
offer a trade there uh if the queens
come off black should be winning black
has two extra pawns
yeah it looks like the momentum is gone
now for prague trading pieces when
you're attacking yeah it's such a common
mistake i think it's that rule isn't it
i mean when you're attacking it was kind
of a do or die situation
because your two pawns down you're
probably losing more material you just
need to get more pieces than the attacks
sometimes it's as simple as that
and that that line that prague missed it
was simply get another rook in the
attack and uh now there's still some
chances here but he's very low on time
and
i could even say black's more better
coordinated should i say here because
he's very well centralized at the moment
this is like the perfect example of a
counter-attack everything has not worked
out for pragnanda and now black is just
ready to kind of coordinate on the light
squares but there is one trick in the
position
one must not forget sleeping bishops and
that little bishop on b1 was threatening
to obscure the queen and king and prague
is using this white bishop right now
it's actually reminiscent of the blunder
we saw with magnus carlsen against
jordan van freest yesterday where there
was a sleeping bishop and suddenly
zoomed up the board and won the game but
of course that check met by a king move
and uh a result in the other game yeah
it is a draw game too it was looking
good for magnus at some point there the
bar was liking it but uh eric hansen
with a white pizza saves a draw in that
game magnus still up by one point before
game three starts he is uh stopping to
take a look at what's happening in
prague's game and magnus will probably
be happy to see this position
do you think prague will be losing this
yes unfortunately the threats of run dry
no more attack for white black's pieces
as simon mentioned is that key word
centralized all of black's pieces
actually protect each other they control
all the entry squares for white pieces
and
no more attack black is simply two pawns
up and the threats continue the white
queen kicked back even further yeah it's
quite cruel chess isn't i was just
thinking magnus is looking at prague and
he's wishing him to lose um as you do
and i think i've been there before as
well that you're wishing people to lose
their game because you know you want to
win the tournament and it's quite you
know
seems a bit strange sometimes hoping
someone's going to lose yeah i i i never
wish my opponents never or my rivals to
lose no because i feel like it's bad
karma and okay prague only has uh 15
seconds left on the clock he has to make
a move he has to move the queen and the
queen must protect the rook
okay so it drops back to the first row
yeah and we see we saw there prague
shaking his head continuing to shake his
head there
head in his hands as well it's the clock
it's the clock if he had one more minute
earlier he would have found that key
move the attack would have continued but
now the connection broken between what's
queen and rook yeah and that bishop it's
on the long diagonal it's beautiful
piece and oh this is a killer blow from
duda
that rook is unfortunately untouchable
knight takes rook allows knight takes
night and then unfortunately the king
and queen are forked but there's no way
to defend against rook takes pawn it is
game over yeah winning in style duda the
white king running away desperately but
now the black rook can take everything
taking a pawn with check uh taking the
knight as well and pragnando resigns wow
that means he is down by two points in
this match against young christoph duda
what a day duda is uh having playing
some fantastic chess and he will now
only need a draw in game three to win
this match